peu
bonsoir c'est valérie mercier
c'est vrai maintenant le derrière
dieudonné le devant c'est comme ça alors
dites-moi veronica je vous ai vu en
photo dans aulas et vous aviez une
europe absolument j'aimerais qu'on la
voit d'ailleurs cette robe serge khalfon
vous aviez une robe formidable vous vous
regarde regarde donc et vous passez
l'aspirateur dans une tenue absolument
délirantes et moi je les trouvais hyper
sexy sur cette photo et je vous ai dit
enfin on vous a demandé de venir comme
ça et vous avez pas voulu pourquoi parce
que je me suis dit pourquoi pas venir
avec l'aspirateur donc à faire non mais
ça c'est une robe hermes étape c'était
juste une robe pour une photo bayer
vraiment clair au caire mais table quand
on voit le corps de ses charges et tu
parles c'est pas facile de me faire des
jeux compris près c'est ici à supporter
le bonnet bon donc bombe donc j'ai très
bien comme ça aussi mais ça m'a chirac
je trouve magnifique maintenant
absolument c'est pareil respiratoires
vous va très bien comme ça chez moi
alors dites-moi quand le quand vous
aviez interviewé clint eastwood la
première question que vous lui aviez
posé c'était que pensez vous de moi à
oui non c'est fort c'est parce qu'en
fait quand j'étais sur m6 je voulais pas
faire des interviews classique et quand
quand le chargé de programme a dit il
faut que tu interview de clint eastwood
mais qu'il veut pas qu'on parle de son
film il veut pas qu'on parle de sa femme
il veut pas qu'on parle de sa maison
jeudi mais du coup on va parler donc la
meilleure chose que je lui dis je lui
dis moi tu fais que brad me oui c'est
une très bonne question
moi si je vous posais la même question
alors que pensez vous de moi ben je vous
dit rien vous êtes très beau l'état fait
quoi mais lui a tendu quoi il a été il a
été père étonné il a mis deux secondes
il a fait et j'ai dit et vous m'aimez
bien je veux trouver qu'est ce que ce
que je fais c'est bien mais moi j'étais
inconnu au bataillon était plutôt
c'était humoriste c'est une vraie bombe
à vous parler d'interviews qui n'est pas
classique cela va pas être classiquement
rue serge est ce qu'on peut baisser la
lumière c'est le voilà
donc valérie et dieudo vous pouvez poser
des questions également un vous aussi
bien évidemment vous connaissez la pièce
en un
alors véronika loubry vous êtes
animatrice chanteuse comédienne
mannequin vous présenter si vous
présentez sur mcm
une émission qui passe le samedi le
dimanche à 18h qui s'appelle les clips
sont à vous c'est ça très bien
alors vous êtes mais je vous présente la
donc cet objet de répondre pour le
moment vous êtes né à saint brévin les
pins
votre maman travail et la sécurité
sociale et voir comment les habitants de
saint brevin brévinois les brévinois et
votre maman dont on croyait la sécu et
votre papa à l'aérospatiale à l'âge de 8
ans et frère ça c'est un creuset déjà
des concerts payants à l'âge de 8 ans
vient je faisais des petits spectacles
pour pour les petites du quartier je
faisais payer effectivement émis sa
maman maman ne le savaient pas les
autres mamans non plus mais c'est une
petite anecdote assez assez marrante
venu chanter vous chantiez là bas je
ressentais pas à l'époque c'était annie
cordy boney m des trucs un peu qui vont
avec et avec l'époque moi j'étais
contente de chanter quoi vient du coeur
du parc attention voilà l'ennemi comme
si j'en sais plus je connaissais le
répertoire parker va dériver frères
jacques
tout ça c'est son choix je pense que
c'est vraiment pas commode d'être à la
mode ouais quand on est bonne du curé et
c'est facile d'avoir du style quand on a
une fille comme moi c'est comme moult
paraître lecture et les piqûres des
grenouilles ccg palace à l'achat tout ça
me gratte au ça donne des idées
d'ailleurs j'ai des loisirs
c'est ma première fois avec annie cordy
bon et alors à la fin vous vous
distribuez des journal de mickey comme
c'est bien le sens de la promotion déjà
en fait mon papa aurait pu fabriquer un
petit théâtre et alors je faisais le
journal mais le journal de mickey en
fait je le lisais je leur demandais de
m'applaudir vost est assez bizarre vrai
je chantais leur donne un goûter à la
fin je les ai payés parce qu'il fallait
bien que j'achète le journal des lycées
foch
c'est alors c'est maintenant vous gagnez
plus d'argent
vous étiez quelqu'un qu'on était bien
vous appelez la commande c'est ça mais
c'est à cause de ça ouais là comment
deux alors en 4e ou d'infirmiers dans
l'est dans les toilettes
ouais c'est avec ces mots que j'ai
regardé par la fenêtre écrire pour
écrire des scénarii vous étiez la fille
de jean paul belmondo du salon mais j'ai
dû dire ça une fois oui c'est vrai je
séchais les cours
josy quoi elle s'enfermer dans les
toilettes pour les scénarii où elle
était la fille de jean paul baysse en
fait on lit un crs on n'a pas le droit
d'être on est dans la cour de récré à
prendre entre dans la classe et moi je
m'enfermais pour pas que les pions me
voit et j'écrivais je passais mon temps
à écrire des scénarii où je m'imaginais
justement pourquoi à l'époque aussi
fille de jean paul belmondo et ça c'est
bon à l'époque il ya longtemps il ya
plus de 20 ans dont il ya plus de vingt
ans booth à l'âge de 3 ans vous est pas
perçu que
vous étiez fait pour faire rire serre
que je me demandais ce que je faisais
sur terre alors qu'angers tendance quand
j'ai fait rire est un peu des gens j'ai
bon j'existe donc là vous monter à paris
après avoir été réceptionniste vendeuse
serveuse a eu à paris pour faire
mannequin pas tous en même temps
non pas tout ça en même temps comme
comme vous d'ailleurs on est tous montés
à paris un jour et alors là ce qui s'est
passé si vous allez à saint tropez pour
faire un casting à 300 candidate et vous
êtes choisis par tf1 c'est quand même le
coup de bol dénoncé dominique cantien
rechercher une fille avait 300 filles à
peu près pour ce casting pour partir aux
bahamas t elle m'appelle trois quatre
jours à prendre dix ans le casting a
duré trois mois et la dernière sélection
m'a dit tu pars dans trois jours aux
bahamas tourner le rêve
ouais c'était super donc vous êtes à
détourner le trésor de pago pago a fait
partie voilà alors après vous avez fait
combien d'émissions s'est jamais sentie
voilà pourquoi je suis plein d'histoires
on comprenait pas bien le jeu ses
producteurs
moi c'est les news non non parce qu'on
comprenait pas bien se passer sous l'eau
on compensait lorsqu'ils passent
effectivement ouais c'était ben ouais
c'était entièrement sous le nom n'a pas
fait le paquebot pago et 13h le trésor
de pago pago alors à préserver une
carrière absolument c'est bien retenu le
type vous leur confiez vous avez une
carrière à 106 à vous passer du trésor
de pago pago aux écrans du savoir sur la
cinquième ce qui est quand même pas rien
après aller sur m6 pour faire star news
après sur tf1 pour faire la mini fureur
vous faites paradis d'enfer
alors voilà on peut pas dire vous ne
trouverez pas méchant si je dis que là
dedans y'a pas un truc qui a explosé le
compteur ça c'est vrai bon non c'est non
non ça s'arrête pas là mais on perd des
opérations
pas si il ya des fans qui s'en
souviennent de star news de sports wii
sports événements si c'était pas mal
c'est vrai que ça pas marqué non plus
dans les annales des jurassiens la
ministre laminé furent d'abord c'était
pour les ados voilà et alors après on
vous fait un disque avec nous ou marach
a quand même écrit les chansons de
jeanne mas et de stéphanie de monaco
staff de malaxer lui qui a écrit au roi
gants et vous fait une chanson qui
s'appelle c dans l'air vous entendez
cinquante mille exemplaires alors
qu'entre 70 milles quand on vous dit non
mais quand on non mais quand on lui dit
que c'est facile mais ça vous dit vous
avez une réponse quand on vous dit que
c'est pas terrible dit c'est quand même
la contenance du parc des princes ben
oui c'était c'était marrant dit hadopi
c'est quand même moi non c'est vrai que
c'est pas terrible mais bon c'est ça n'a
pas été bien suivie à chaque fois moi
j'ai pas eu de pot j'ai eu des problèmes
avec la prod ou avec la maison de disque
est toujours un problème donc c'est pas
très grave
ceci étant c'est le fait d'assumer ce
qu'on a fait moi j'assume j'ai passé des
bons moments à chaque fois que j'ai fait
quelque chose j'en ai tiré de des bonnes
ou des mauvaises expériences leurs
preuves leur ferait pas le tout moi j'ai
aimé ce que j'ai fait à un moment donné
dans ma vie voilà le problème c'est vous
dire si vous avez jamais été vais jamais
marqué une case à la télé je la sais
tout faire que si vous aviez tous au
même endroit pendant longtemps mais j'ai
tellement bougé
vous avez beaucoup bougé voilà ce que
vous avez raté aussi vite que les
téléspectateurs
c'était une bonne façon a marqué me
sentais surtout tombée sur vous même
souffle avoir vu véronique à la
télévision non voyez par exemple voilà
parce que c'est ça peut-être pas une
bonne vous pouvez vous aimez pas on va
en parler après votre rapport à la télé
est ambiguë ça fait un rapport ambigu à
la télé oui bon je me souviens que vous
êtes venu chez vous à chanter la chanson
assez censé endiguer la chute et randy
lâchez vous enchante en direct c'est
même la dernière émission de france en
chantant dimanche en direct
ça s'appelle dans tous les sens et c'est
pas tout mais c'est pas tous les jours
une chance non pour moi toujours chaud
mais non c'était bien débrouillé c dans
l'air s'était passé dans l'air c'est pas
si mal de 50000 exemplaires non mais je
peux compte nommer 60
dans l'air et danser dans la résidence
est dans l'air c'est dans alors donc en
revanche sur le plan privé jamais eu
tellement de problèmes donc parce que
d'abord vous êtes sortis comme on dit
avec alexandre debanne qui est plutôt un
beau garçon si j'avais pensé mais si
bien sûr vieillit pas ben oui alexandre
et yannick souhaitait connaître
après trois ans après un accident après
l'accident juste avant l'accident
et alors à près de vous non non non ce à
cause de la moto est alors après vous
êtes je vous ai tous
non mais j'ai raté deux trois fois si je
te disais suivait déjà si on bosse
ensemble il faut que tu bosses mais
voici mais j'ai raté de trois mois si je
suis parti chez le dentiste pour la
lâcheté on peut pas dire les gens disent
j'achète voici je ne sais pas moi si je
le vois chez le doigt là c'est ça voilà
je crois pas c'est donc je reçois gratos
et à la radio je serai et c'est la
première chose sur lequel on se jette
tout se tient d'ailleurs lundi vous y
êtes là c'est vrai à merde avec vous non
mais alors et après donc vous rencontré
votre mari qui s'appelle robert therry
taous et sa vérité teriitehau alors
j'avais bien compris il est champion de
windsurf ou de funboard windsurf fn dans
la même chose c'est pour ça c'est pas
une question des gens qui disent faire
mais s'est mis d'accord
et alors quand vous l'avez rencontrée
c'est tellement le coup de foudre est
vraiment eu un vrai coup de foudre
vous êtes resté dix minutes avant de
pouvoir poser la première question c'est
pas vrai c'est vous qui l'avez les
appelez pas été écrit mais en tout cas
c'est vrai qu'on parle pas la même
langue déjà rejoint mai
ce qui est écrit et ce qui est vrai vous
le savez pertinemment voilà c'est fait
loin de là alors non c'est pas vrai non
c'est pas vrai c'est vrai que c'est lors
d'une interview
j'aurais pu lui parler tout de suite
mais bien sûr en revanche j'ai dîné
ensemble le premier soir ça vous en
bouche un coin ça bah moi j'ai du mal à
arriver à faire ça à ses fils alors le
terreau idéal allégeant le premier soir
alors vous à vous dînez dinars
nahdhaouis dîner à merci alors bon vous
êtes vous avez tous été très très très
clair l'un vis-à-vis de l'autre avec la
crise comme ça ils ont redit on a déjà
nous nous avions déjà il vous reprenez
vous manque vous avions déjà bien vécu
chacun de notre côté et on se l'est pas
caché non ça j'ai jamais dit ça non plus
ça m'ennuie sa planche mon aspirateur
voilà on a fait des ménages mais c'était
l'amour fou parce qu'une fois il paraît
qu'il est revenu de du pacifique pour un
week-end à deauville c'est vrai son mari
habitent hawaï
bah je sais oui et c'est vrai qu'il faut
plus de 22 heures d'avion pour venir il
est venu pour un week-end mais le fait
souvent effectivement
ouais bon beh mengue deux heures pour
retourner chez vous n'avez pas chez lui
l'autre haletante partira alors vous
partez comme s'est fait laminer fureur
vous vous dites je pars hawaïen si ça
marche je reviens sinon si si la mini
sur leur marche pas je reviens pleut et
ça n'a pas marché vous êtes revenu
pourquoi je n'avais pas dit je dire ce
n'est quand même pas à la fête c'était
diffusé qu'en moi j'étais hawaï et c'est
vrai qu'on m'appelait tous les matins
pour donner les l'audience est sûre je
voulais je voulais pas revenir tout de
suite parce que quand je reste un vrai
jeu reste de trois mois et en fait j'ai
été rappelé pour faire autre chose pour
passer des questions pour le cycle est
ce que c'est pas parce que vous trouvez
pas vos brouillons cuba voyais pas ce
que le ça c'est n'importe quoi c'est pas
vrai j'ai jamais dit ça j'ai dû
m'arrêter de dire j'ai jamais vu ça j'ai
dit vous avez dit le seul problème
j'ai dit que je n'arrivais pas à trouver
tous les ingrédients pour faire de la
cuisine parce que moi je cuisine non
mais c'est pas attendez c'est pas parler
des bouillons de cube j'avais dit qu'en
général je trouvais rien quoi oui non
mais c'est quoi c'est pas ses pattes
donc robert y laisse effectivement à 18h
devant des drapiers robert dit bob bob
09 le ca ressort babeuf 0 et à 18 heures
de vol dont kiel à construire c'est
normal j'allais y allez-vous lui vient
mais vous y allez vous oui une semaine
tous les tous les deux moi c'est ça non
non je suis allé deux mois la novembre
avant qu'il a construit une maison pour
vous là bas moins il avait construit
avant que j'arrive à bon compte jeudi on
est au mois d'avril
oui mais il est bénigne est emballé tout
le monde se demande alors à tan aliz à
une semaine tous les deux jours
tout le monde se demande tout le monde
se demande c'est pas tout le monde en
parle c'est tout le monde se demande
mais vous avez dire j'espère faisait pas
confiance parce que c'est une phrase que
tu assez joli je trouve en vous avez dit
avec robert on se voit pas tout le temps
et vous avez dit c'est comme les bonbons
quand on vous en priver le jour où vous
les sucer quel bonheur
[Applaudissements]
la porte c'est un vrai
vous avez dit suce t elle un jour ses
écrits laissés comme un bonbon quand on
quand on en a plus on en a envie et
quand on les a battus voilà j'ai dit ça
j'ai pas d'issue c'est du tout bon c'est
pas le thé non j'ai mal j'ai mal est
fait c'est vrai cette phrase mais pas
bon je vais faire un bébé pour lendemain
non ah ouais même que vous aidez moi
j'aime bien faire un bébé en tant que ça
près de trois mois
valérie l on veut pas pas prononcent pas
pour l'instant pas ça je me dis jamais
rehab air france sont dit pas pour
l'instant à bertrand c'est fini alors
latéraux que j'ai fait c'est une
boulette moi c'est la grosse boulette
l'annoncé il ya la moindre des choses
c'est de se renseigner
c'est parce que vous faites parce qu'il
ya peut-être un homme devant sa
télévision là qui est complètement
inespéré
et qu'est ce que vous lui venait de lui
faire à cet homme thierry ardisson et et
à valérie compris valérie a su surmonter
grâce à ce film voilà elle s'est plongée
dans le corps et âme
ce succès met mais là vous avez fait pas
je suis effondré là j'ai fait la
boulette mais je sais que vous êtes
effondrée je le sais sincèrement
effondré mais bon je sais que vous vous
en aurez assez facilement et rapidement
mais mes pensées aux autres voilà voilà
télévision faut aussi penser j'ai
toujours bon alors vos projets on va
terminer sur vos projets veronica si
vous voulez bien parce que vous dites
chaque fois que j'en parle mais projet
ça n'aboutit pas et j'ai l'air ridicule
mais je vous préviens vous avez dit je
rêve de faire fort boyard mais qu'on
compte pas sur moi pour faire d'inde à
côté d'un animateur c'est pareil cccc
d'un je sais pas où vous approchez pas
pour les raisons qu'on leur a dit dom
c'est pas un mot à moi c'est marrant ce
que moi je suis pour tous à ce qu'on
dise qu'on ait dit ou pas dit mais les
journalistes ont tendance à donner
députés les propos acerbes
je sais pas pourquoi je dis pas
d'instructions vocales dont elle voulait
faire le père fouras j'ai finalement
elle n'avait pas la clé pas les grossman
est trop grand ce territoire est
mannequin est trop grande pour faire
passer partout
enfin je suis dit je sais que c'est sur
cette chaîne mais quand même
voilà énervant fort boyard 45 minutes
pour retrouver cette clé c'est nous
énerve déjà au bout de cinq minutes
quand on a perdu les news j'ai pas
regardé ça n'en voulait plus faire
potiche c'est vrai quoi c'est oui c'est
à dire que la sur mcm show une émission
qui me plaît interviews des gens qui me
plaît ça et ça change un petit peu c'est
vrai sinon je vois ça change un petit
peu effectivement de toute façon quoi
qu'il arrive dans les émissions que j'ai
fait quand t'es à côté d'un animateur
tu es un peu relégués au rang entre
parenthèses j'ai pas dis d'inde est
peut-être dit potiche
parce que l'animateur vous pas qu'on
dise plus que enfin pas plus que lui
mais il veut qu'on veut pas être non les
faire-valoir de l'animateur c'est vrai
que c'est assez dur maintenant sur un
thème je suis tout seul
deuxième où le maintenant à droite je
reste là méritent bien sûr une enquête
très finement
valérie a tout de suite remarqué chez
téléfilm jeter vos soeurs valoir bon
alors vous avez quand même votre
entreprise de savon au monoï n'ont
toujours non oui c'est de la fleur de
tiaré c'est pas une entreprise
je ne connais pas du tout effrayé une
beauté c'est moi qui l'initié faire tout
de suite on va dire qu'on voit dans le
film à quel point à quel point vous avez
été convertie par valérie lemercier aux
produits de beauté on va voir ça tout à
l'heure bon écoute et on a fini dernière
question comment va votre ami katchou
super tu vois je vous serre ges qu'on
peut voir que vous êtes très amis là on
va vous voir toutes les deux avec catch
ou la voilà sont très amies toutes les
deux donc et même max avec eux ici voilà
ouest et le calendrier
c'est bien ce calendrier maya décembre
voilà prochaine pour garder comme ça
c'est issa ces caches où c'était
vraiment c'est véronique à ça c'était la
différence à grenade remercié c'est que
valérie fait pipi debout devant le film
bon merci beaucoup je te trouve plus
sympathique que cache ou huawei a
beaucoup plus sympathique
avant on peut pas à balancer sur quel
chemin et s'est vexé pour quelques
questions vous prenez et ça je trouve ça
vachement agréable tout avec le sourire
oui on lui dit que c'est une dame
et ouais ça vachement sympa non mais
cache ou comment ça va au fait avec sa
fille chouette cette fille là quel show
commence avec son jules
enfin vous allez arrêter tri on a parlé
ici moi j'ai joué c'est pas elle qui va
vous qui vaquent à la série de notre
dame de paris là vous parlez très bien
timsit
oui c'est ça plus vrai ici alors comme
vous le savez chers amis chers ennemis
il ya eu un petit scandale cette semaine
c'est à dire que les galeries lafayette
dans leurs vitrines ont mis des
mannequins vivants
donc on va en parler dans un instant
avec roselyne bachelot qui s'est insurgé
contre ça en vous disant que ça
ressemblait aux prostituées d'amsterdam
vous connaissez des prostituées
d'amsterdam et bien sûr tout le monde
connaît qui mangent des frites comme
[Applaudissements]
exactions ne s'était pas député donc on
va en parler avec elle j'accueille pour
l'hyper view roselyne bachelot
m
soir enchanté de faire votre
connaissance laurent vous connaissez
roselyne non on note que les pubs du
rose chez elle allée du dos mais habillé
de rose de pied en cap 7 à seattle et
même se saoule mais c'est plus fia oui
ça va il s'agit andré bercoff je pensais
qu'il avait un pantalon cuir et non oui
et roselyne que je sais que ce serait
reçue chez syros et marielle différence
entre autres officines boutin et madame
bachelot elle est rose fuchsia et
l'autre héros se fait chier festival en
plus un petit hors champ sur l'épaule
pour vous confondez halak à ferrara
phase
c'est cet équilibre petits rôles à c'est
ma petite couture et c'est vous qui
l'avez dessinée c'est très joli bond
roselyne donc vous savez ce qu'est une
hyper ça c'est pas terrible a dit je me
moque pas des c'est de vous la donne moi
vous venez de faire des compliments à
ces deux dames et rien à la maison parce
qu'elle n'a pas voulu s'habiller comme
je voulais c'est alain de la tricoter
c'est bien roselyne vous connaissez
l'hyper view il n'avait pas beaucoup de
laine jupe et review
on en veut à tous vous posez des
questions se rendrait à prendre et vous
pouvez poser des questions à roselyne
valérie peut poser de monique pauzé
c'est le principe de l'hyper view on se
met à cinq contrats alors roselyne
bachelot va vous appeler en fait
roselyne j'ai vu bachelot narquin parce
que le nom de votre père c'est marca
bachelot ces deux noms de votre premier
mari est alors souvent en politique on
garde le nom et vous regrettez
maintenant d'avoir commencé votre
carrière professionnelle sous un nom qui
n'est pas l'autre parce que vous avez
divorce est maintenant de jacques
bachelot c'était un problème de beaucoup
de femmes
on commence sa carrière sous un nom le
nom de son mari
je lutte pour que les femmes gardent
leur nom de jeune fille parce que les
hommes passent et le nom reste avec
jacques et j'accueille et pourtant
pourtant vous lui aviez payer ses études
à
vous aviez tout fait pour jacques bon il
va troudi qui s'appelait yvette horner
ou des jamais dû changer alors
maintenant donc l'hyper duo va vraiment
commencer serge khalfon est-ce qu'on
peut mettre le voilà à on est mieux là
l'âge et fuchsia dans les yeux de ces
grosses de rachel ça va ça vous plaît
pas non non non vous êtes caissier très
voyante si tout les cantons vont voix
quand on vous voit on est d'accord pour
qu'il ait plus de femmes à l'assemblée
avait vraiment c'est pour ça vous moi je
suis pour qu'il ait plus de femmes à
l'assemblée moment parler après vous
êtes né le 24 décembre comme jésus à
minuit à minuit vous êtes capricorne
comme jésus as un bon signe capricorne
en vieillissant sont vierges à onsan
d'envié comme jésus c'est très bien vous
êtes député du maine-et-loire député rpr
alors vous dites toute façon le rpr
c'est ma famille parce que il ya une
chose c'est réel c'est incroyable c'est
que le général de gaulle vous embrasser
quand vous aviez neuf mois et demi et
c'est un peu comme dans le temps quand
napoléon avait embrassé quelqu'un s'est
passé ensemble c'est ce à quoi c'est une
sorte d'adoubement rivesaltes à chaque
fois mon père m'a emmené le général de
gaulle m'embrassait depuis ce temps là
je dis rien
bah oui voilà alors votre père était
résistant pas été député avant des
députés étaient résistantes et ftp votre
mère était féministe donc on comprend ça
explique un peu aussi votre vos
positions actuelles quand même deux ont
été levées là dedans donc votre cv comme
ça on victoire à votre cv vos activités
vous êtes présidente c'est assez
étonnant parce que c'est pas très
politiquement correct vous êtes
président du groupe d'études france irak
et du groupe d'amitié france syrie
donc on va pas faire une soirée tricyle
sur les ide pour l'europe de
l'association parlementaire ou à revoir
donc ça c'est rare en plus des gens qui
s'engagent comme ça pour les pour les
pays arabes en france on va pas faire
une soirée triste m'enfin vous vous êtes
témoin que les bombarder des gens ça
sert à rien en irak en tout cas
certainement pas oui je suis allé
visiter l'ira qui a à peu près un mois
et demi et j'ai pu constater sur place
la la détresse des populations
c'est assez terrifiant voilà mêmes les
israéliens qui ont bien
un filtre et lun's comme disque saddam
n'est vraiment plus dangereux dans tous
les experts militaires internationaux
sont d'accord pour dire que le potentiel
militaire irakien est complètement
détruit le potentiel nucléaire chimique
alors creuse l'irak ont fait des trous
partout en irak on trouve rien et on en
droit irakien prouver que vraiment y'a
rien vaut très difficile voilà donc on
va pas s'étendre là dessus mais enfin on
en conclura ce qu'on voudra sur d'autres
frappes alors vous êtes vous soutenez
aussi la cause palestinienne enfin vous
n'êtes pas très politiquement correct au
contraire c'est très peu j'entends les
bords j'entendais beaucoup de gens se
plaindre qu'on ait repoussé
l'indépendance de la palestine d'un mois
et demi alors 6 4 mais s'il quatre mails
palestinien n'est pas mais pour
proclamer que ça retarde d'un mois c'est
pas très grave
d'accord mais si véritablement ça
mettait ça m'était en saura un jour on
sait très bien que ça se fera en
dominant non payées mais le chant devenu
un qui met pas à qui n'est pas appliquée
bon le problème c'est pas vraiment entre
les palestiniens et les israéliens
contre les juifs et les arabes eux
manifestement oui si je veut résumer
grossièrement oui c'est encore plus
compliqué que ça enfin on va donc enfin
sur politique voilà c'était simplement
pour dire que vous étiez quelqu'un
effectivement on va passer maintenant à
vos autres positions politiques mais
enfin ne serait-ce que là-dessus déjà
vous avez des positions qui sont pas
banales alors vous êtes beaucoup engagé
pour la parité homme-femme vous publiez
un livre alors avec quelqu'un qui est
pas du tout de votre bord et geneviève
fraisse qui est numéro deux sur la liste
de vente des rues voilà donc je le
montre à la caméra comme on fait la télé
voilà c'est blanche neige à l'est
derrière robert lui signale que
geneviève fraisse et pour les
bombardements de l'otan
oui tout à fait donc cdac que c'est
intéressant c'est de se confronter et là
pas du tout votre bord et alors il n'ya
pas sur la couverture ghislaine
ottenheimer qui pourtant a participé
tout à fait nullement au livre donc on
le dit on le dit l éditeur donc ça
s'appelle deux femmes au royaume des
hommes chez hachette littératures donc
sur la parité vous avez dit aux
sénateurs de droite qui étaient contre
la parité
il avait une occasion de se racheter de
temps de vilenie contre les femmes
depuis un siècle de république
ils n'ont pas saisi l'occasion quelques
ont pour eux un c'était pas pour les
femmes parce que je pense qu'on va très
bien se débrouiller sans eux mais c'est
vrai qu'ils avaient une belle
lyon d'apparaître pour peut-être parce
qu'il n'était pas et ils ont été fidèles
à leur tradition c'est pas tous pas tout
ça mais traite humaine
je ne sais pas traiter de vieux cons
voilà c'est dit deux ponts n'étaient pas
justes tout comme un vieux con ça aura
été son pardon demandé pourquoi volet de
leur dit de quelqu'un et paquets le bit
au nom justement de la parité
ah c'est vrai vous avez raison ça me
révolte un peu tandis qu'on pour
employer justement pourquoi on a fait de
ce mot con un mot péjoratif
alors vous aurez traité de beats aura
été aussi fort et vous aurez été dans
vos noms et prénoms mais quelquefois je
dois avouer qu'ils sont comme une [ __ ] à
d'accord quand commune des deux
vérificateurs comme une bête ça c'est
pas mal ça vous êtes pour la parité vous
à l'assemblée nationale où vous vous en
foutez complètement non je m'en fous pas
je m'en fous ouais non je sais pas parce
que si on peut mais non non non je pense
que soit je ne suis pas pour qu'on mette
un nombre de femmes à nombre de jeux je
pense que soit on est doué qu'on peut
bien je sais pas je trouve que les
quotas j'aime moins les quotas que parce
que vous pensez de 95 % d'hommes qui
sont en politique ils sont voués à non
non non j'ai eu peur
non jamais je ne sais pas vous moi mais
bien mais je me dis que de faire
absolument un quota il faut 50% de
femmes 50 % d'hommes 50% des voix là où
dans les films il faut un noir un
chinois une femme homosexuelle un bain
je suis toujours un noir il y avait déjà
donné dans la plaie en partie position
il y avait eu ce qui va arriver
nous on est dans l'écouté mais
maintenant je trouve ça très bien qui
donnerait à la politique elle est sur la
ligne d'elisabeth badinter c'est
universel on s'attendait à la fois moi
je suis pour
vous êtes d'accord
si on commence si la parité ça n'a rien
à voir avec l'universalisme de la
république c'est clair on commence à
faire des segmentations entre les gens
pourquoi un jour on dirait pas à
l'assemblée il faut qu'il y ait ce que
les 13% d'homosexuels 15% noir ce que je
ressens la différence sexuelle n'a rien
à voir avec toutes les autres
différences elle est fondatrice de
l'humanité toutes les autres différences
son contingent transitoire vous avez dit
la véritable égalité comme ça c'est
qu'ils s'emmerdent s'est passé ça c'est
une boule quies non c'est une heure est
donc dans le car on dit la touche c'est
tellement il est terrible il nous l'a
prêté c'est juste un petit moment là
parce que moi je suis pour ma part je
crois aussi tiré j'ai accepté une
prothèse auditive parce que vous étiez
peut sourire
ouais parce qu'il ya un truc ya ma mère
elle dit toujours comment se fait-il qu
ardisson qui est plus petit que toi sois
plus grand à l'écran est comme ça tout à
coup ça la culture
non si vous la trouvez ça l'est mais là
non seulement pour des talons mais il a
des porte-jarretelles csq l'ars en bons
vous la rendez donc là on m'explique
quand ça n'est pas ma came à deux
secondes
alors madame barbe blanche et lui parler
lui l'eau
oui c'est madame parent de huy où c'est
en train de ses parts de marché
j'entends un petit bruit de fond non je
pense que c'est ça ne marche que sur
vous ah parce que moi j'ai l'antenne qui
valait trois milliards
il ya des trucs ça tombe bien il va
lever 3 milliards ça m'arrangerait bien
au skins machin je sais pas alors
roselyne vous avez austin powers boothe
c'est celle du clea lemercier ce genre
de film vous avez dit la véritable
égalité c'est quand il y aura des femmes
potiche à l'assemblée sur le compte de
l'égalité
c'est comme il ya des députés petitie
aussi des députés potiche femmes
c'est ce que je vis valérie quant à lui
dit ah oui tout le monde ait choisi sur
ses qualités sur ses mérites en
politique c'est évidemment pas vrai ça
se fait je ne savais pas voilà on est
dans un milieu dans mon travail où ce
n'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
voilà bah ouais il ya des gens marc
marquez encore il faut que je fasse du
cinéma c'est parti pour vous est
vachement doué avec boutin bonne
comédienne assise là elle est meilleure
que moi non non non non alors là et
louise
on vient de parler du pacs je me
redresse bien pour que la maman de l'or
voilà bien de parler rappelle mes années
avec jacques martin sympa alors non on
vient parler de la parité sur le pacs en
vous êtes de bons vous avez vous avez
marqué contre votre camp on peut dire
vous êtes devenu danger marqué pour le
mien pour le vôtre vous êtes devenu
d'après le magazine têtu qui est une
lecture très saine vous êtes devenu une
icône gay dire que vous êtes devenu une
idole des gays une madone des aussi je
vous avais fait la couverture de têtu
comment vous êtes vous êtes tabloïds ont
plus que les journalistes un journal gai
de lyon qui est très très bien faits
dont vous êtes une icône gay alors quand
quand vous êtes à l'assemblée et que
vous vous prêchez comme ça pour pau pour
le pacs les gens vous disent roselyne tu
as tu prennes aux pattes c'est vrai mais
ce que je trouve extraordinaire c'est
que chaque fois qu'une femme a un peu de
courage ou un peu de personnalité on
fait une comparaison viril
oui j'ai entendu et voilà une femme qui
a des couilles et là mon film c'est ce
qu'on dit de martine aubry on essaie
secondé par les couilles en plus voilà
moi j'attends qu'un jour on dit d'un
homme courageux il à dessein oui avec va
bien ça le cap on dit ça n'inquiète pas
le pape leur avait dit tout ça n'est pas
comme il l'a fait contre l'utilisation
du préservatif ne voulais pas qu'ils
encouragent la débauche et là elle à la
décadence le pape en fait c'est le jean
pierre coffe religion votre cellule
sachez que c'est pas mal quand c'est
drôle
bon oui d'ailleurs vous alors vous avez
des expressions marque et vous êtes vous
fait vous avez fait un discours à
l'assemblée puis en sortant comme ça
c'était très dur pour vous ce discours à
l'assemblée donc sur le pacs et en
sortant vous dit
ouais c'est un peu j'ai un peu perdu les
pédales quand même si vous êtes la
bienvenue
n'importe quoi ici quand on vous parle
j'ai moi aussi j'ai un peu perdu au
sujet vous savez du outing c'est à dire
que act up voulait dénoncer le député de
droite qui avait qu'homosexuel et qu'ils
allaient manifester contre le pacs est
un des députés de droite ont moussé que
ça avec députés de droite homosexuels
mais c'est un scoop c'est un travail
très intéressant à votre avis aura
combien écoutez moi j'ai fait ma liste
pour vous dire des non non non non non
non non non le nombre
et quand ils ont menacé de là où tu es
je regardais les gars qui étaient
complètement blanc dans les couloirs et
je me disais pas que ça y est celui-là
blanc très bien les voici
vous avez déclaré le sujet que je tends
à tintin commission parlementaire au
sujet de ses députés vous avez déclaré
dans tabloïd ce n'est pas parce qu'on
est homosexuel qu'on est pour le pacs et
vice versa avouez quand même que vous
avez des formules oui ça rhénan est la
raison oui et vous avez dit d'ailleurs
la sexualité du député en question je
m'en tape
ou plutôt je me retape d'annoncer une
marrante
elle est chouette parce qu'ils ont
laissé très peu en fait est ce que
finalement vous dites nous tout ne pas y
repérer que je ne sois pas non si c'est
vrai quoi d'habitude les femmes ont
marqué c'est pas vrai parce que comment
il s'appelle c'est mon côté maso
françoise de panafieu est plutôt bon
mais aussi entre femmes du rpr on ne
connaît pas très bien pourquoi on reste
je m'en reste le chinois tout en sa non
mais vous avez quand même un sens vous
avez dit si vous avez un ami vous êtes
comme malgré tout comme un peu leur père
parce que j'ai un ami qui est mort du
sida et vous avez dit qu'à la fin de sa
vie il était en rupture avec la
surconsommation sexuelle façon cyril
collard qui ne peut conduire qu'au
chagrin au désespoir et à la maladie
donc vous avez quand même
thiam pour vous les [ __ ] les bombes et
les cdp des sages quand même le nom ils
font ce qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils veulent
la même vous avez celui-là il
et ils avaient beaucoup souffert dans sa
vie et il avait souhaitée avec un ami
établir un lien entre tous oui on peut
souhaiter vous dit quand même que mon
arrivée il en était arrivé à un couple
sage contre la surconsommation sexuelle
type cyril collard tu as quand même que
vous critiquez quand même un peu le côté
back room
si oui je critique pas chacun fait ce
qu'il veut mais il ya des gens qui sont
malheureux 4 que vous précisiez pour les
téléspectateurs qui ne savent pas tous
forcément ce que c'est qu'un backrooms
vous avez un style chrome n'est pas une
épreuve de répétition pour les candidats
au bac n'ont pas de persuader tout le
monde sache ce que c'est qu'un bac 1 bac
rhône dans les boîtes vous allez vous
savez ce que ça va très bien y aller
mais je mange pas que les hétéros qui
vont dans les bordels sont malheureux
mais enfin je suis les bordels ont été
trop m'attendais à tabac de marthe
richard andré vieille histoire ça ne
m'est cher mâchoire qu'il faut pas
généraliser
ouais y'a pas il ya des surconsommateurs
sexuels qui sont très heureux il ya des
gens qui ont dans les bois dans les
boîtes gays dans les boîtes gays
il ya des endroits un peuple en noir
noir comme ça bascule où on va on va ou
ne va pas on n'est pas fou il se passe
des choses assez libre disons 1 et il ya
déjà des parois comme ça avec des trous
dedans dans la paroisse qu'on appelle
des glory au challenge
je savais pas qu une rumeur regarder
promettent nos admirateurs enfin
expliqué me raconte alors le glory hole
on passe on passe bien aujourd'hui rien
de glorieux l'on passe son sexe c'est
pas possible les filles on passe son
sexe en grès rose sais pas qui vous
valérie fait pipi mes repas non merci de
vous messieurs
[Applaudissements]
je crois que dans l'oreillette qu'elle a
gardée au vient de lui dire qu'il y en a
1 derrière le studio et les parties
vérifier en fait alors le bio vidéo buzz
et le glory hole donc c'est un petit
round ont accueilli les parents avec des
petites où on passe son sexe dont le
petit trot que j'essayais de tape le mur
et a derrière il ya quelqu'un qui vous
fait ce qu'il veut mais ne savait pas
qui s'est beaucoup donné en retrait
me dites pas que vous ne connaissiez pas
les glorieux mais moi je connaissais pas
je connais les backrooms je fais pas
l'idiot mais je ne savais pas qu'ils
avaient savais pas que c'était comme si
je fais comme ça que ça thierry serait
ce que vous avez vu ça dans un bac rom
mais qui sait taper je sais pas une râpe
à fromage ici j'en sais rien mais alors
essayons de dire que l'assemblée
nationale c'est le back room du sénat
d'après vous même c'est le bon alors
finalement passé la soirée avec sa lampe
torche
absolument est-ce que vous est ce que
finalement vous n'êtes pas utile au rpr
est-ce que tu as tellement vous n'êtes
pas un peu vous fait du bien on y repère
quand on voit à françoise de panafieu
comme on l'a vu ici quand on vous voit
vous vous faites du bien ou vers perth
évident peut-être parce que quand je
vois le nombre de collègues qui m'invite
à tenir des réunions de leurs
circonscriptions après m'avoir voué aux
gémonies je me dis ils sont quand même
c'est vraiment la base des hypothèses
mercier dans tes bras est ce que vous
êtes gaulliste de gauche ou
progressistes de droite gaulliste de
gauche vous êtes gaulliste de gauche
elle a pu les charbonnages a embrassé
sur la joue gauche charles de gaulle
numéro deux sur la liste de jean marie
le pen se fait gerber et là moi je pense
qu'il est plus de la famille du
porte-avions du général il a un peu trop
court pour réussir à faire décoller le
pen l'argent de gaulle son frère la
renier oui très bien que ça brille ça
m'étonne changerait pas d'accord sur
tout mais qui fait partie des goodies de
gauche le petit fils en fait c'est ça
oui c'est le cas de ce genre de boulot
c'est le fils de l'amiral dont vous
voulez vous êtes vraiment c'est jurassic
park homs et que les gaullistes de
gauche y en a plus on viendra y avait un
euro et rené capitant jean pierre chéret
mamelles oui je vais chez les gaullistes
de gauche et pasqua alors oui un peu max
gallo régis debray sont un peu des
gaullistes de gauche
alors depuis 68 la droite court après la
gauche c'est ce que vous faites pas la
même chose faite depuis 68 finalement
les gens de droite non mais voilà c'est
ressembler à la gauche quoi ces plans
technique et c'est là c'est la défaite
idéologique elle est à gauche on garde
des jasmins ils essaient d'imiter la
droite il fait une politique de droite
the way c'est évident il a renoncé à
tous il a capitulé en rase campagne
il fait une politique il n'a rien à voir
avec la gauche c'est pour ça qu'ils
réussissent mais c'est depuis mitterrand
ça c'est vrai oui d'accord
strauss kahn il fait pas tellement peur
aux bourgeois c'est vrai on s'en veut
pas dire qu'on n'est pas dire non à
plusieurs sur le coup au gouvernement on
parlait jamais j'attends vos interviews
pourquoi non parce que ce je préfère ce
qui m'amuse c'est de me moquer des gens
qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de voir et
voilà non mais sans vous en vous moquer
des gens pourriez parler politique sans
vous en match et mes jeux j'en parle
d'ailleurs dans le derrière je me manque
d'une certaine gauche caviar qu'on voit
jamais au cinéma donc
sans dire sans imiter sans être
imitatrice de gens de l'homme politique
je pense que ces politiques de tout à
coup se moquer d'eux c'est un peu rue de
valois votre personnage de laisser des
gens qu'on voit jamais au cinéma on voit
toujours les hommes qui brasse de
l'argent et les gens qui travaillent
avec la culture se salissent jamais les
doigts avec de l'argent mais non c'est
vrai qu'on est meilleur quand même du
pouvoir mais c'est très déroulé veut pas
vu encore il faut aller voir ça ça vaut
une voix non mais sérieusement je dis
pas ça parce qu'elle est là parce que je
le dis depuis que j'ai vu le film il
faut aller voir ce film c'est formidable
c'est une caricature de la gauche caviar
pierre berger blanc là vous allez
vraiment rire on va là derrière avec
christine boutin chinois vendenheim
alors dites moi il ya peu de députés
femmes donc je crois qu'il ya 5,6 pour
cent
là on est dit un peu plus de 10 à 10
quand ça oui on doit être au niveau de
la grèce maintenant oui on était en
oeuvre en dernière place on est passé en
avant dernier devant ça va être l'enfer
pour vous qui est plutôt jolie fille non
parce qu'ils sont très dragueur les
hommes politiques non l'animateur aussi
je constate
parce que les hommes politiques ne
drague jamal et femmes politiques nos
draps que des pétasses
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi alors françoise s'il voulait
être la compagne de françois hollande
c'est bizarre mais là non c'est un
couple là c'est un couple légitime à
bâle
les hommes politiques drac plus que les
autres
par pourquoi ce qu'ils sont habitués à
séduire parce qu'ils sont je crois
qu'effectivement il ya plusieurs raisons
d'abord et un caractère de l'homme
politique qui porte à plein d'énergie
être ensuite la politique c'est très
durement qu'ils ont besoin de se
consoler sur un ca maternelle assez le
repos du guerrier voilà et puis
troisième raison c'est qu'ils ont
l'occasion bobonne vous attend 19h15
19h05 vous n'êtes pas là j'ai envie que
j'ai le comice agricole qui s'appelait
le truc
et puis ce sont des rock stars ou pis
militants voilà c'est vrai qu'à la
cheffe de parti arrive quelque part et
qui tient meeting et que l'appétit
groupe y est là mais c'est un oignon
quand il sort de scène ya cinquante
femmes qui m'attend c'est donc le
chantier pas le dit d'ailleurs quand on
voit le nombre de mines est qui
tournicotent autour des vieux gros c'est
incroyable c'est qu'il ya plein de mines
est tout le temps de raymond barre je
suis sûre tiens à vous rappeler c'était
henry kissinger le pouvoir est
aphrodisiaque
c'est comment tu arrives toi avec ta
gueule à avoir tout ce que tu as et
disait pouvoir aphrodite les hommes
politiques c'est vous qui le faisait
remarquer c'est que quand ils sont la
tribune il c'est bon riff un peu ils
deviennent un peu tout rouge comme des
coqs
c'était quelque chose de commun les
orgasmes hic oui voilà il ya une montée
de ce en quoi
mais les femmes alors vous n'êtes pas
dragueuse non au citoyen ajouté
oui non plus en faire le tour m pétrole
et je dirais même que c'est c'est même
l'un verse cette richesse
non mais
ça chez moi vide et un sur trois il faut
alors public vous dit roselyne bachelot
les il s'est lâché et ça lui fait du
bien
l'émission est finie c'est ce qu'on
voulait vous avez dit safin avant
d'avoir tous à vos pieds parce qu il
aime ça en plus les mecs syfy savent que
même si c'est bien récupérer avait
détruit une famille française à l'opéra
et vous est-ce que vous êtes un jeu
krauth est ce qu'avec votre jules vous
n'êtes pas que c'est non on ou non mais
vous appeler toute la journée il paraît
sur le web et il est éteint la halal
portage portable lui les deux mais c'est
vrai que les hommes politiques qui sont
un peu l'habitude de tripoter les gens
chirac par exemple il tripote les gens
les vaches aussi le contact est très
fragilisée par les craintes de barthez
c'est pas compliqué cela dit vous avez
des chiots être superman mais dites donc
je les terribles
alors parce que c'est un jeu vous n'êtes
pas élu vous venez faire l'émission a
pas de problème on vous engage
vous dites que chirac quand il est
question des familles vous horripile we
will m'horripile à peu parce qu'il n'est
pas pour la conception volontariste de
la parité de là je vais commencer dans
l'oreillette à faire dire que ça c'est
bien
non me dis que ça va encore dire que
vous êtes très bien lui c'est un vrai
séducteur du président de la république
ah oui oui c'est un oui c'est un vrai
séducteur c'est un vrai trip auteurs non
il est bien
alors pour conclure cette petite hyper
view vous jamais non et véronique un bon
signe vous avez un portable avec avec
robert vous appelé dans la journée sur
le portable
ah oui donc si vous êtes obligé avec le
décalage horaire vous vous êtes quand
vous vous couchez il se lève non halal à
diminuer cette affaire un drôle d'effet
ça quand même
en effet vous sentez pas toute seule
fois ci là je me sens très salée marie
laforêt ne regardes tu ma vie wd je
viens dans l'émission j'ai vous diront
côté un peu sur vous parce que l'on s'en
doute véronique non mais moi je respecte
les couples coûte ils s'aiment c'est
formidable même si à 12 heures et trois
océans entre eux il aura tout de même de
france
vous avez déclaré
vous avez déclaré roselyne les hommes
doivent apprendre que les femmes ne sont
plus tout à eux tu dises vous avez dit
ça mais ça m'a fait de la peine parce
que ma petite femme je pensais qu'elle
était tout un mois et ben non c'est pas
émerveillé mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
les hommes doivent apprendre que les
femmes sont plus tout à chérie tu sais
pas moi quand ça m'avait b du tout à moi
non non bon bah voilà le moment donc où
j'accueille rachid djaïdani que vous ne
connaissez pas je vous montrais son
livre donc ça s'appelle bunker on en est
à 40 mille exemplaires d'un livre très
étonnant très bien écrit le personnage
de l'est pas moins donc vous allez faire
connaître quelqu'un que vous ne
connaissez pas rachid djaïdani
[Applaudissements]
rachid djaïdani
bonsoir voisine mme bachelot député rpr
mes repères coulin valérie lemercier
chanter pascal légitimus
on se connaît on vous connaissez ouais
j'ai connu mes cheveux un peu plus long
ah bah voilà et - écrivain et moins
écrire alors ok que vous connaissez
alors rachid on vous a demandé de venir
parce que vous êtes un personnage
étonnant
votre livre donc bunker que je montre à
la caméra comme ça comment fait la télé
zoom zoom bon garçon voilà un zoom zoom
zoom mon gars dessous
quant à carros et de mieux donc bunker à
40000 exemplaires
- ouais c'est bien alors pour moi moi
moi en fait ce que j'aime dans ce livre
c'est pas un livre qui raconte ça ça
raconte les sites etc
mais c'est pas que ça parce que ça sinon
ça serait un livre de sociologie ça
serait un livre de témoignages une
convaincue c'est super bien écrit je te
remercie non mais c'est vrai alors ce
que je voudrais qu'on fasse simplement
si vous pouviez lire la quatrième de
couverture
ouais parce que comme ça on va voir tout
de suite c'est c'est des phrases un peu
comme dans le rap c'est des phrases qui
tourne c'est on sent quand on confond
tempo alors voilà quand on le lit comme
je l'aï demandé ça quand on le lit on
entend on entend une musique ça tourne
alors juste la quatrième de couverture
tout va bien basi rachid tu me dis go je
te dis bon ok mon âgés de 21 et verts
s'est improvisé je précise
ouais ok monajed 21 hiver je porte un
jeans 501 un pull bleu sur mon poignet
droit une gromett en un jean avec le
prénom d'un mail mot des femmes qui
frangin j'habite au deuxième étage d'une
tour d'une des tours de la cité
je suis au chômage j'aime bien la vie en
général mais j'aime pas le rap des
variétés qui me parle de bouger de là et
qui me dit de me balancer les bras en
l'air parce que ma vie fin qui je suis
un requin assassin grâce à la morsure de
nos phrases et j'aime bien les gens
sincères qui défendent les causes
sociales
j'aime pas sos racisme ils viennent dans
nos quartiers uniquement lorsque ces
primes quand même sur le dos de nos
cadavres qui font l'audimat et enfin
j'aime bien les grands frères du
quartier qui préfèrent toucher leur rmi
plutôt qu'en filet des rangers pour
surveiller des magasins qui
n'appartiennent même pas l'heure
r je me planque avec mon pote grésy qui
a commis une bêtise à la sortie d'une
école trois points de suspension
je fermais guillemets où sont nos
repères qui sonne au modèle de toute une
jeunesse vous avez vous brûlez les red
bull et les haines brisé les rêves tag
la salle de l'espérance suprême ntm ses
premiers romans récits de rachid
djaïdani 25 piges excellent scénario the
man écrit ça tourne ça tourne très bien
il ya du style comme vous dites
dissidia du spa il ya du style mais
c'est vrai c'est très très bien merci
alors il ya juste un petit problème il
ya déjà deux fois c'était trop beau ni
maintenant
vas-y non c'est pas toi c'est pas ça il
ya deux fautes d'orthographe
page 14 je ne je m'étais fait confisquer
et page 86
il s'était fait carotter et j'ai changé
d'éditeur et j'ai fait pour dire
regardez ses banlieues ça c'est vous
c'est un honnêtement qu'ils aient fait
des fautes ou pas de faute la profondeur
à aller dans l'histoire ouais après
c'est superficiel d'accord mais où alors
c'est un moyen pour vérifier si
l'animateur a lu le bouquin danse est un
jeu en fait oui c'est pour voir un jeu
radiophonique mais là tu as donné toutes
les réponses donc faire le bouc avec
plusieurs fautes et comme ça on mettra
106 si jamais tu avais lu le récit à
l'origine c'était pire c'était beaucoup
plus placé les deux fois qu'ils ont pas
enlevé en fait voilà enfin c'est un
cadeau qui m'ont fait bon les mecs de
mon quartier on peut baisser la lumière
on va passer à l'hyper view donc voila
merci c'est lorsqu'elles font alors au
sol quand ils ont su le manuscrit ils
sont dix ils ont eu peur qui est un
[ __ ] en fait parce que ce sont dix ans
non non je suis vexé on part toujours de
moi ça me non parce que il ya un riche
qui est sorti charbon il ya deux ans qui
s'appelait lille a10 a6 nouveau chimot
qui avait été écrit en fait par des gens
je dis pas comme vous et moi mais comme
vous et moi et qui n'était en fait
qu'une à la manière de quand ils ont
peur que
c'était écrit par un parent par quelqu
un par un par un [ __ ]
ils ont reçu écrit ce fut écrit par
écrit
ce fut écrit même embêtant mais qu'est
ce que j'ai fait peu parler pour la
chine vont évidemment c'est bien vous
qui l'avez grille vous dites vous dit
quand vous parlez du bouquin vous dites
je savais que je leur avais donné un
beau caillou ouais c'est clair c'est
clair la preuve aujourd'hui quarante
mille exemplaires ouais donc c'est pas
ce cas ni bon ni pour moi quoi ouais
parce que j'ai pas tricher ils ont ils
ont tout de suite percuté au soleil tout
de suite directement c'est tout de suite
ils m'ont pas mis les menottes non je
déconne c'est de la callas quoi ouais
c'est alors vous avez signé le contrat
aidé que vous aviez le chèque en poche
c'est vrai que vous avez disparu en
angleterre de joueurs partis y voit un
mois en angleterre aux fins de la boc
parce que je me suis dit c'est pas
possible ils vont me rendre le chèque
obligé way et mono omis d'autres après
peut-être ils vont me le reprendre
en tous les cas là on rigole là c'est un
succès c'est un gros succès piscine
ainsi que c'est pas fini mais vous avez
passé un an
un en dur avec rayonnant loi mais j'ai
mis 25 ans dont le rêve est quoi on sent
que chan qui laisse entrer ici oui
l'oeil c'est ce qu'ils veulent c'est ce
qu'il sait où il va c'est bien vous avez
d'autres chèques tu veux d'autres chaque
chrétien qu'elles sont laissés du silex
a fait des étincelles
vous l'avez écrit ce livre c'est parce
que chez vous chez vous quand vous
l'écriviez on vous disais mais qu'est ce
tu fais tout à toute la journée dans ta
chambre en train d'écrire ce bouquin m'a
dit ok qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'évidemment pour des gars comme moi
enfin maintenant tâche en prenant part à
une piste ça fait un peu bizarre dans la
tête des neurones de nos parents quoi
moi et donc ils ont été un peu ça a été
un peu bizarre boureux quoi mais au
final j'ai écrit beaucoup dans ma
chambre énormément aussi à l'institut du
monde arabe et beaucoup de temps d'entre
métrage et c'est à dire dans le rer dont
beaucoup dans le rer c'est à dire
l'autre enfin bon je vais pas jamais
secret mais l'autre histoire
tout est écrit dans le rer ouais ouais
ouais une autre histoire encore il faut
pas dire alors quand on vous demande
pourquoi vous avez écrit ce livre vous
dites pour prouver que les gens comme
moi qu'on regarde comme des pitbulls ont
une sensibilité loin mais en même temps
on a aussi des morsures qui égale celle
des pitbulls ouais ok dès l'instant où
il ya du respect et de l' écoute on est
l'amour m'ont balancé des émotions comme
là quand je regarde mais dès l'instant
où il ya l'agression on est laboureur
ont répliqué c'est toute notre culture
mais sensibilité oui pitbull non mais
c'est quand même tm qui a fait la
préface quoi ils symbole cadeau pour moi
parce que pour moi c'est comme elles
viennent des mec pas très fréquentable
quand même
disons que pour toi pour toi j'en ai
rencontré une fois devant la maison de
disques sony il a failli me mettre en
morceaux très musclé c'était pareil
mettez kabylie en état en hôtesse de
l'air peut-être enfin je vais je vais
pas revenir sur un thème parce qu'en
même temps c'est tellement de facilité
de rebondir là dessus dans ma mémoire je
t'en prie mais pour moi ce sont des
grands frères quand j'étais gamin qu'on
avait une petite télé noir et blanc
c'est bien eux qui revendiquait nos
émotions enfin en tout cas les miennes
et aujourd'hui je suis content d'avoir
d'avoir fusionné qui me fasse la préface
du livre auquel gaulliste de gauche
ntn ça vous choque quand même quand ils
disent préférer c'est bien vers des
sacrifices vous voulez mais bien sûr
vous allez dire oui mais tout le monde
va dire oui parce que la question est
tellement facile je suis pas là pour
défendre le suprême je suis l'amour
revendiquer mon livre il n'y a pas de
problème hautement revendique à bhl
alors vous avez une attitude quand même
racine oui il faut aller plus loin que
la question il ya chez parée ntm ça
choque tout le monde puis quand il est
là ça choque plus mais non justement
c'est pour cela que j'insiste vous vous
vous prenez une chanson de ntm et vous
remplacez flic par juif ou par aram qui
vous lisent et puis vous voyez l'effet
que ça vous fait
au pire un caramel voilà parce que moi
je le donne l'impression d'être le seul
qui ait choqué par un témoin je ne pense
rien pour faire tout ça je je ne pense
rien je trouve que tout est bien à mort
j'aime j'aime bien tm j'aime bien son
livre je vous aime bien j'aime bien rue
qui viennent pas manifester même si cela
d'après ce que j'ai pu entendre sur le
4e canton dit bouge de là
oui parce que ma vie et funky dans ce
soir par exemple j'ai l'opportunité
d'aller voir dieudonné ça monsieur que
je respecte énormément et est pour moi
voilà quoi j'ai vers les gens qui me
sensibilise il est venu vers moi donc je
suis juste là tétouan mais vraiment
enfin ensuite tu vas avait un verre
inverse ce que la saba quoi audi voter
pour le meilleur de ce qu'il a pensé de
ntm qui compte ceci de fait un bon ami
son bouquin est excellent on l'a déjà
dit cent fois mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que quand on quand on parle d'un
thème ici généralement tout le monde il
va quand même ils exagèrent de casser la
gueule à des hôtesses de l'air il ce
soir yann moix a l'air de chocolat
limité
une hôtesse de l'air mais c'est sa femme
surtout peut-être ce qui se passe si tu
veux je vais écrire un livre sur un
personnage qui ressemblera peut-être à
dio et ça te rappeler de méthane v
dessus mais là ces bunkers
d'accord ça din din céline c'était un
[ __ ] oui c'est un bon écrivain ou sur
une bonne nuit toute façon il a fait l
tm fait la préface alors en même temps
sur la sur la vie des cités sur la vous
dit quand même que il faut se prendre en
main et qui a pas de place pour les
pleureuses
c'est clair c'est intéressant d'en venir
parce que ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
ce qui se déroule depuis de longues
années genre depuis de longues années ce
qui se passe genre le mec il s'écoute
quand il parle de hockey c'est que
effectivement on a plu aux jeunes qu'il
fallait revendiquer ou casser la mairie
pour obtenir
moi je dis c'est une chose mais la
meilleure des choses c'est de prendre en
main quoi qu'il arrive il faut lutter
pour tes propres émotions beau il faut
aller de l'avant quoi il faut arrêter
que de croire que il ya des barrières
rien et tu peux pas tout attraper mais
il faut rêver tout est possible et je
n'en pas tout est possible moi je les
fais ça a été du travail tout et du
travail mais il faut rêver vers son
travail et ça peut s'obtenir peut-être
et quand vous dites pas de du travail
j'entends attention jeu justement ce qui
est étonnant en discours de rachid
djaïdani c'est que il en parler dit faut
cependant main il dit le problème de la
banlieue c'est avant tout une histoire
de frustration sexuelle
c'est des choses qu'on entend rarement
c'est vrai mais c'est aussi une réalité
on est toujours en meute
ouais donc quand on aborde une fille
qu'on se retrouve à 15 on l'abordé
forcément ça fait non ça fait émeutes
vous dites si l'état montre ses
faiblesses a aussi encore plus je dirais
non pas politiquement correct mais
presque en fin de prêt en tout cas plus
étonnant si l'état montre ses faiblesses
plus la tentation est grande pour les
jeunes de montrer les crocs ben ouais tu
vois des policiers enfin on n'est pas là
vous faussez drôle que moi aujourd'hui
je suis amené à parler de ça alors que
j'ai même pas fait les études qui
peuvent revendiquer que je puisse en
parler
voilà j'en ai beaucoup doit se lâcher
c'est l'école buissonnière ce soir voilà
regarde ce qui est ce qui est assez
drôle c'est qu'aujourd'hui les policiers
dans tous les documentaires qu'on peut
voir à télé wire ils n'arrêtent pas de
paul pleurer revendiquer qu'ils ont
passé le matériel revendiquer que c'est
dur revendiquer ceci revendiquer à
regarder les jeunes lancent des cailloux
ban et toi tu es jeune tu vois un
policier s'est froissé fragile sensible
donc c'est un homme donc forcément tu
feras qu'associé ça ça donne de l'eau au
moulin on va dire ça aide à faire le
geste un peu trop vite recule finalement
ça donne envie de lui taper dessus qua
non si le flic pleurs oui ok ça donne
envie pas forcément lui donner des
kleenex mais il se tient en fin de
compte n'a pas choisi la bonne voie donc
passez de l'autre côté couet flic ou
voyou quoi pascal légitimus
ouais mais j'adhère à ce qu'il dit de
toute façon c'est il dit des choses
tellement vrai tellement temps rarement
ben oui mais il ya des humoristes qui
elle elle l'a fait et beaucoup de voix
ce qu'ils disent des choses mais c'est
faux s'est fait sous la forme d'une
mouche de moi qui parle de choses quand
même assez grave
la base de l'humour c'est à dire des
choses g est un peu décalé et sauf que
lui le 17è première en parler c'est ça
d'une part lui c'est le deuxième mais
bon voilà
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que on
permet aujourd'hui à ce monsieur d'en
parler à la télé bien à 5-6 ans était un
peu effectivement avec les inconnus ou
des parodies de déjà lieu des cités tout
à fait parce que pour nous c'est un
phénomène tellement fort à l'époque que
maintenant c'est devenu banal mais à
l'époque ça nous nous choquer
positivement de voir des jeunes qui
avaient envie de ces prêts à travers une
musique à travers des choses comme ça
que l'on entend ce que je veux dire je
fais ce que je veux signaler c'est que
ce que ce qu'ont fait les inconnus par
exemple ça a jamais joué contre les mecs
du quartier alors qu'aujourd'hui a
beaucoup d'humoristes on va pas les
citer mais bref cette façon je suis pas
l'amour pour faire la guerre même si à
fait que commencer
c'est que il y en a beaucoup qui ont
trouvé la facilité de faire un accent
vasile un vêtement mais comment on fait
et ça fait rire tout le monde dans la
salle moines message aux autres nous
croire différence c'est que nous on aime
nos personnages c'est important dans la
compassion pour les personnages que que
loin qu'on égratigne un petit peu ça
c'est important sinon ça devient de la
vengeance personnelle et c'est vrai que
c'est pas très sain effectué les
humoristes sur cinq qui font ça à vous
ma vitre est votre radio
et c'est parce que maria se diriger une
espèce de marketing de la révolte mais
moi je me suis moqué de sa aussi
d'emmener respect c'est se moquer des
gens qui disaient ouais t'as mais je
trouve ça tellement tellement la fin à
cet essai pour faire jeune âge aiment
pas le jeunisme je n'aime pas qu'on
veuille faire jeune à tout prix qu'on
veuille être marche dans le sens du poil
aboyer avec les loups alors aussi de
vous ai fait de la boxe avant de la plus
belle chose qui me soit arrivée dans ma
vie et
c'est un métier tellement magnifique
vous êtes le ring m'a donné le goût du
combat je suis un guerrier je
n'abandonne jamais pensé que ça vous à
ma disons que ça te fait comprendre que
la vie c'est comme le ring c'est à dire
il n'y a pas de là il ya pas de plage
rebondissant ce que j'écris a pas de
place pour les pleureuses du serre les
dents tu vas en avant et tant que la
décision n'est pas donné il faut pas
lâcher
quoi qu'il arrive a lâché parmi les
jeunes des cités de banlieue et mâcon
bien comme ça qu'ils disent pour qu'on
sente à il faut qu'on y arrive et on
nous ment on arrive c'est ça que je veux
faire signaler on arrive et c'est pour
ça que j'ai dit ça fait que commencer un
coin de la place ça veut dire ça veut
dire que on est là et maintenant vaut
aussi goûté au gâteau quoi allez vous
allez donner maintenant on a un peu de
votre salaire qu'à tous ceux que ce soit
la bonne idée j'ai pas de questions
posées monsieur après la gears shit
c'est bien là bien sûr non mais attends
tu vas nulle part ailleurs la saison
prochaine
alors vous avez fait beaucoup de clips
vous avez fait des séries là vous faites
un le rôle principal dans un long
métrage est une superbe aventure qui se
déroule devant moi effectivement grâce
grâce à ce bébé quoi ouais c'est à dire
je travaille sur un sur un film loin des
sentiers de la racaille c'est à dire le
personnage n'est pas vas-y la vie de ma
mère et la comédienne enfin je peux les
citer ça dérange pas mais ça ne dérange
personne
merci beaucoup c'est fabienne bab et le
réalisateur c'est jacky katu et puis mon
fric ils m'envoient que des bonnes
choses et que du positif
et c'est bien parce que moi j'ai pleuré
aujourd'hui les gens pour moi mais tu
dois être content mais c'est enfin je
vais pas refaire ouais c'était tellement
dur mais c'est une telle souffrance
comblera pas un seul casse tout y'a pas
trop loin
non mais moi si je suis bien là il n'y a
pas de problème mais en même temps
c'était tellement dur pour le pondre
tellement dur bourbon le faire c'est pas
comme georges en série le jeu ne sait
trop qui à leurs petits qu'est ce que tu
as fait aujourd'hui
ouais j'ai écrit une page tu vas la lyre
valeur à nos amis ouais non nous c'est
ton père ni bien qu'est ce qu'il fout là
dedans tu te décris toi tu es encore
qu'est-ce qui se passe tu vas tu va
pondre les poussins là ou quoi
laisse moi je suis travail talât je me
racontais des points ne sais pas c'est
pas comme genre d'un ordinateur
tatata 1 bis qui fonctionne bien t'as du
papier blanc n'en vas-y batwa gao le
succès de jamel debbouze c'est
magnifique mois déjà mais je l'avais
joué au tuyau lui qui avait vingt
personnes à la fin on pouvait lui faire
la bise quoi aujourd'hui qu'il va vous
la faire lui faire la bise soin de
prendre un avion en coréen vigie du
monde stopper cadeau mais c'est super ce
qui se passe quand on pose la question
quand tu imagines que le gars il vient
de trappes est il là il a demandé dans
un quartier dans une tour quoi est
aujourd'hui fait le succès qu'il fait
comme on dit abdoul elah merci mon dieu
pour lui quoi je suis vraiment fier bros
djamel je suis vraiment fier pour tous
les jeunes qu'ils soient issus du rad de
la littérature du cinéma qui s'en
sortent et sans baisser leur fera une
question djamel dit souvent dans ses
interviews qu'il est croyant est ce que
vous êtes croyants
monsieur bien sûr toute façon nous on a
grandi dans cette culture ou la religion
est très importante parce que ça me
permet d'être face à toi et de pas une
idiote je suis pas une [ __ ] quoi tu
vois tu la vois ce qu'ils aient quelque
chose à dire
virginia où je disais que pour écrire il
fallait quelque argent et une chambre à
soi et lui n'avaient pas d'argent il
n'avait pas de chambre il a réussi à
voler bien passé je leur montre la
caméra soit bunker de rachid djaïdani au
seuil donc à part les deux fautes
d'orthographe que l'éditeur a laissé
c'est très bien mais je vais la pensée
la tête
[Musique]